the Joe Rogan experience do you have
well water we're on the around the
spring that comes down from Inga's
Mountain so Jerome is on on spring water
and then we have well town on the other
sites so your tap water spring water mmm
Wow so do you have does anybody add
anything to it probably because it's a
it's it's a talent so they try to treat
it just to be safe
yeah unfortunately Sarada we had a well
we have - we have three wells I like
each site has its own well as you get
spring water which rights because we
have the you know we have the Oak Creek
and that's that's at the page spring is
right there so we have water dish rights
that we actually irrigate the vineyard
on those but I went ahead to put in a
well on every one of them just as a
back-up plan did you get a guy with the
stick trying to figure out where the the
water is the diviner guy is that she at
work worked for us how is that real I
don't know I don't know I had a buddy
might have built a well on his property
and he had the guy come over with the
stick I'm like I can't talk to you
anymore I want got that I want to say
like they know that there's a general
area where the water it is yeah there's
some dude with a cell phone in the
corner go watch that watch this you
think I think it's right here but it's
the thing it's a lifetime lot of
practice but I've seen it I've seen I've
seen it done we're like he's just
walking around on said whoa it just goes
down like oh really let's go here yeah
how the [ __ ] can that possibly be where
you don't know it's good here it is
here's this guy it's called water
twitching water we uh what's witchcraft
look at this guy [ __ ] this guy I'm
looking away he's moved his hands [ __ ]
her too she's full of [ __ ] to look at
him oh I ain't even done ready to be
controlling this right here right here
okay shoot shoot the [ __ ] out of here
with that
that's nonsense that's like three-card
Monte hey [ __ ] I've drilled four
wells and they'll burn or would you just
try to drill a well out of the [ __ ]
blue just whistle somewhere yeah
ten ten paces right here BAM
under a bucket of network of Wells yeah
the only thing I worry about wells is
every movie where there's bad people
they always throw the bodies in a well
like the Larsen Tarantino he can't
really fit the body down that no I think
it's a two-edged thing tink but you can
try I mean those people that have
yourself a lamb meat grinder or some
hogs guess you're good
remember the well baby the kid that fell
down the well it took like days to get
him out mm-hmm Jessica yeah yeah it was
her right yeah I said him yeah and she
eventually became like a hot hot broad
here's another guy doing it he's calling
this is called a dowser I might be might
be multiple names divorce whether I'm
not mustering this guy is a bottle of
water on the ground and he's like
proving well how about we put a bottled
water where he doesn't know where it is
yeah it's lined blind him right he's
moving his arms
this guy's a [ __ ] he's like the worst
magician ever he's really like moving
czar nothing under my feet presto watch
his hands [ __ ] you [ __ ] you Melvin John
Baker professional dowser professional
hoser he's a hoser this guy John if
you're listening I'm sorry I'm just this
is comedy I'm sure you're real I'm sure
you would do what you're doing is real
bro let me see let me see your hands
let me see your hands I don't see hands
what oh Jesus look at it it's moving
down with my coincidentally my hands are
thrusting down at the same time yeah
nonsense he's a professional dancer
what's the name of the religion they
have the snakes that bite him in the
face Pentecostals yeah those are my
favorite those are the folks that talk
in tongues mmm-hmm there's no
Pentecostals talking tongues I'm
thinking I'm conflating them I don't
think they necessarily the snake handler
I was I was raised Southern Baptist and
we did some tongues did you oh yeah
Sam I'm on my ding-dong you have to do
that like that one really I didn't say
it like that because that would be you
know what was his name is it Robert
Paulson is that the guy he's like the
slicked-back hair preacher he does that
he'll just be on in the middle of
talking about Robert Tilton that's right
amazing
[Laughter]
one of my all-time favorite quotes every
time you write a check to me Satan gets
a black eye that's a farting preacher
yes yeah that's him yeah yeah that's
good
he's a dowser as well yes it's out there
in the backyard with some sticks
[Applause]